okay just say no the tornados latitudes
now
I just don't think you're gonna see
anything right now there's a lot of
precip surrounding what's a little
tornado in the center so there's a big
eye and a little eye so it's gonna be
very hard to see it's something when you
can see the tornado coming at you and
you can prepare yourself to be hit
there's another thing to kind of have
your eyes closed and to have this
monster that's kind of lurking in this
huge frame curtain
Josh now directs tip toward the
intercept Sean takes the ready position
pointing the front of the tip into the
tornado the front is designed to
withstand the most violent winds and
debris
it
regular water
wind speeds outside reach nearly a
hundred and five miles per hour but the
science data logger attached to the
instruments on the tip isn't recording
and Sean abandons his IMAX camera
because it's too dark
still the basic idea worked
they found a tornado and they
intercepted
you wouldn't call it a dry run but it
was a great test drive